Speaker 1: Let's hear from people people like you
in the audience. We do calls via Discord David
Pakman dot com slash discord is the place to get
in touch with me. Let's go first today to Vince
from No. Vince is gone. That's too bad. Let's go
to Jason from Toronto. Jason, you're on the air.
Dave, can you hear me? I can hear you fine.
Speaker 5: Hey, it's a pleasure. I've been
watching your show for a while
now and I want to say that
thanks for taking my call and thank you and
work on your end. What you do is invaluable,
so I really appreciate that. My
pleasure. A quick question for you.
If Trump were still in power, how do you think
you'd be handling the situation in Ukraine?
Do you think he'd just fold his hands over the
situation and keep the U.S. out of the situation
to kind of appease his relationship with Russia?
How do you how do you think he would approach it?
Speaker 1: So I think in the this is a good
question. In the lead up to the invasion,
Trump would have placed heavy doubt on the
intelligence about Russia massing troops at the
border, about Russia imminently invading. He would
have resisted that significantly early on, and he
would have sowed distrust about the intelligence
that pointed in that direction. And he would have
said stuff like, You know, why would Putin do
this? I don't know. I don't think so. Putin
denied it very strongly or whatever that would
be in the lead up once the invasion takes place.
I think Trump would have similarly early talked
about genius savvy Putin, just like he did. But
then, as everybody around him starts to say,
we've got to help Ukraine here. This is this is
a war of aggression being waged by Putin. Putin's
clearly the aggressor. We've got to do something.
I think Trump would have reluctantly been kind
of pulled in to helping Ukraine in some way. And
it would have been similar to when Trump, on
the day of the riots, put out that statement,
saying It's time to go home. You know, he's like,
We love you. You're here for the right reasons,
but it's time to go home. It would have been a
similar sort of like reluctant help of Ukraine.
That's the way I imagine it would have gone.
Speaker 5: Yeah, and I appreciate that as well.
I think NATO and the Western resolve against this
or position this would be greatly diminished had
Trump still continue to hold the office there.
True. I'm kind of glad that we have somebody there
with a little bit more of a level head taking
care of it because I think would be much different
had you still been around 100 times that much.
Thanks a lot for taking my call. I appreciate it.
Speaker 1: Thank you so much. Appreciate
it. All right. Very good to hear from you.